pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre je veux évoquer ici
ce qu'on appellera peut-être demain
l'affaire vilemotte stéphane vilmotte
est maire de une commune du nord au mont
qui a vu l'expulsion d'un imam salafiste
à la suite de son courage et puis de la
volonté du du Préfet et du ministre
c'était on ne peut plus normal puisqu'il
faisait des prêches apologie du
terrorisme mais aussi de remise en cause
de notre modèle républicain il est
aujourd'hui en Algérie alors ça aurait
pu s'arrêter là mais seulement demain
Stéphane vilmotte à la suite d'une
citation directe de ce triste individu
sera devant le tribunal alors il s'agit
pas pour moi de faire une quelconque
pression sur la justice elle est
souveraine naturellement mais de poser
quelques questions légitimes première
question est-ce que c'est opportun
est-ce qu'il faut se poser la question
de modifier la législation et c'est le
sens de l'amendement que nous avons
déposé avec Stéphane demilli j'ai des
doutes sur la question mais vous y
répondrez faut-il renforcer
l'accompagnement et et l'aide des
préfets et des procureurs sur les maires
par rapport à cette question faut-il
prolonger le délai d'enquête enfin
toutes ces questions se pose mais ma
conviction notre conviction elle est la
suivante il faut absolument ne pas
laisser les maires seuls c'estes
soutiers de de la République face à
cette question des mariages de
complaisance qui risque de se multiplier
au moment même où nous renforçons à
juste titre et légitimement les
questions liées au au droits des
étrangers je vous
remerci la parole est au ministre de
l'Intérieur merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs sénateurs monsieur
le sénateur h je veux d'abord après vous
souligner le courage de Stéphane V le
maire de Haumont dans le Nord qui grâce
à ses informations à son action dans
cette petite commune par ailleurs
charmante mais qui a peu de moyens à
interpeller le préfet du Nord vous-même
et et moi-même pour pouvoir expulser cet
imam étranger qui exposer une version de
l'islam moyenageuse radicale
insupportable et oui nous avons réussi
grâce à l'action du préfet du Nord à
l'expulser et il n'est plus sur le
territoire national avec une
interdiction de retour sur le territoire
national vous avez raison de dire
monsieur le sénateur que par ailleurs
monsieur vilmot paye cher pour lui et
pour sa vie personnelle celle de sa
famille son courage et d'abord il a
l'entière soutien l'entier soutien bien
sûr de la République du ministre de
l'intérieur des services puisque à
plusieurs fois j'ai échangé avec lui et
sa protection bien évidemment physique
lorsqu'il a été menacé je crois que vous
avez parfaitement raison sur les
enquêtes qui doivent durer plus
longtemps sans doute pour permettre à un
maire ou un officier d'état civil
lorsqu'il agit en dél gtion notamment de
l'État en l'occurrence des services de
la justice lorsqu'il a un doute
lorsqu'il a un doute pour la véracité de
ce mariage et même si un étranger en
situation irrégulière c'est
constitutionnelle a le droit de se
marier sur le territoire national en
aucun cas en aucun cas ça ne fait
obstacle à son éloignement ça a été le
cas évidemment pour le cas évoqué aussi
à la mairie de Bézier où bien sûr cette
personne a été expulsée malgré le fait
que le procureur de la République a
demandé au maire de Bézier de faire ce
ce mariage il y a donc monsieur le
sénateur à réfléchir sans doute dans le
cadre de la immigration puisque nous
avons adopté hier soir un amendement de
Monsieur bit sur la reconnaissance
frauduleuse de documents et notamment de
paternité passant à un délit de 5 ans et
à une peine de plus de 75000 € d'amande
il y a donc à réfléchir et nous sommes
en train d'y réfléchir donc n'hésitons
pas à y travailler ensemble soit au
Sénat soit à la navette soit dans la CMP
pour permettre au maire de décider
vraiment lorsqu'il a un doute sérieux
est-ce que ces services lui ont permis
comme c'est le cas de Monsieur vmot de
le documenter de s'opposer à mariage
lorsque les gens ne veulent pas se
marier par amour mais par intérêt contre
la
[Applaudissements]
République merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre réponse merci d'avoir
souligné le le courage de Monsieur
vilmotte Merci de la volonté de l'État
enfin en tous les cas on a un devoir
c'est de ne pas laisser les maires seuls
parce que je pense que ce cas n'est pas
un cas unique et qu'il risque de se
multiplier par rapport à les tentatives
ou tentations de mariage de complaisance
je vous remercie si la est maintenant au
président Cédric